as we've been talking about this
probably comes as no surprise to you FBI
director James Comey has officially
confirmed that the FBI is investigating
Donald Trump campaign connections to
Russia and Russian interference with the
2016 election that's not news at this
point okay what I have not yet discussed
with you and I'm going to do right now
is that we've also found out that the
FBI appears to be investigating
right-wing propaganda news websites
Breitbart
and Infowars Infowars of course the
right-wing conspiracy website of Alex
Jones earlier this week anonymous FBI
sources told the news website McClatchy
that the 2016 presidential election led
to automated or or saw automated Russian
computers strategically posting
pro-trump
news articles from Infowars from Alex
Jones's program and from Breitbart
during times in the campaign where
things were not looking so great for
Donald Trump and the FBI is reportedly
looking into whether bright part and
Infowars were directly coordinating with
Russian operatives in promoting their
stories the Russian computers were
mostly posting the articles to Twitter
and Facebook and a great deal of the
articles consider contained falsehoods
not surprisingly I think most people
most rational people when you hear about
articles from Breitbart and Infowars
being posted by Russia to the Internet
most reasonable people would assume that
there were falsehoods in some of those
articles but for the bots to be posting
the articles to social media the
question is would participation be
required by Breitbart and Infowars the
answer is no but that's exactly what the
FBI counterintelligence looking into
they're trying to figure out was there
communication or some degree of
collusion between Infowars & Breitbart
and Russia as all of this went on and we
know Pat that Breitbart and info wars
were not only big proponents of Trump
they were also constantly defending and
taking the side of Russia much
the way that Trump has done so it's it's
sort of uh it's very interesting that
this is going on it's not conclusive yet
but it's also pretty obvious that this
would be something to take a look at I
really wonder how Alex Jones will
respond to this because it kind of plays
into his narrative that the government's
trying to crack down on him and silence
him yeah and he hasn't been able to
really go after the government much as
of late because he's still on the Trump
train right but if there's an
independent agency like the FBI he can
still kind of do that because of course
they're also investigating the president
you're still calling the FBI independent
I noticed that I mean it's like it's not
if they're able to do an investigation
against the president there is some
independence there you would think so
yeah now whether whether they are making
some decisions for political purposes I
guess is different from whether they're
presumably independent as of this
morning as far as who's commented the
White House Breitbart Infowars and the
FBI have all declined to comment on this
for the time being you would think
though and this I think gets to Pat's
point you would think that if Breitbart
and Infowars had not been coordinating
with Russia wouldn't they have issued
some full-throated denials so far and
again if they have in the last two hours
then I take this back but as of two
hours ago at least when I last
researched the story they hadn't and in
the same manner you can apply the same
logic to the Trump Russia thing if Trump
and Russia hadn't had anything to do
with each other you wouldn't expect to
see constant lying from trump officials
flynn Manafort Trump himself seemingly
Jeff Sessions about connections to
Russia why lie if there really is
nothing to hide I've not gotten a good
explanation for that so far and if they
don't lie outright they give these very
lawyerly answers yeah I think that
there's going to end up being very
simple answers to these questions and
they're gonna be so simple that they're
going to expose why the people lying
we're lying all along that's that's my
prediction and we'll see